a Seattle high
schooler was just marked incorrect on a
quiz for saying that only women can get
pregnant uh there was a
quiz on on understanding gender versus
sex this was administered by a 10th
grade ethnic studies world history
teacher what what are they teaching in
school e ethnic studies world history at
Chief SE International High School and
the student was marked wrong for
answering the question that uh all men
have
penises as a true statement and also
marked wrong for saying that only women
can get
pregnant is a true statement so for the
first question I guess there are freak
accidents right I guess there are kind
of amp know surgeries going wrong or you
know I get technically speaking I guess
not all men
do no women do but some I guess some you
know God forbid like awful you know but
could be a freak accident but then the
second one only women can get pregnant
that leaves no
doubt obviously only women can get
pregnant but then Zoom back out what
class is this in ethnic studies why are
you sending your kid to study ethnic
studies that's a that's a pseudo
academic discipline that is strictly
from the very beginning it has only ever
been a a political operation to
indoctrinate students in a far- leftist
ideology deriving from critical theory
and the the various critical studies
departments that proliferated in the
universi now apparently in high schools
in in the 60s and
70s then furthermore what's the quiz the
quiz is called understanding gender
versus sex so if you believe that there
is a hard and fast distinction between
gender and sex and the two have nothing
to do with one another as the left
believes if that's the premise of the
quiz then I got to ask
you why are you sending your kid to this
school you know what you're getting
going in the school is not being
dishonest
here look I think there's a distinction
between gender and sex I know it's not
popular for a lot of conservatives to
say that but I think there is and I
think it's it's really a modern lib way
of talking about the distinction between
the body and the soul I disagree with
the way the libs talk about the
distinction between gender and sex
because I think that the body and soul
are inextricably linked and the soul is
the substantial form of the body so I
think that you know if if you f if you
feel a disagreement between your gender
identity and your sex the reality stems
from your biological sex because I think
that sex and gender derive primarily
from the matter of the body not from the
form of the soul and it applies to the
person as a as an Inseparable accident
of the individual for as long as you
exist as an
individual okay I bet that that's
nowhere on that quiz but that's the way
that our civilization has thought about
gender and sex for all of
history so if you want to teach your
kids that you you can't send them to
this
school if you are a
parent why would you subject your child
to this and furthermore forget about the
parents I don't know the circumstances
maybe it's the only School in the
neighborhood what kind of country
subjects students to this what kind of
country intentionally Mal educates
students intentionally alienates them
from reality makes them Dumber makes
them confused about who they are and
potentially entices them to fall into
ideologies that will harm them and and
may well reduce their life expectancy
but but furthermore just what kind of
country puts their kids in classrooms to
make them stupider and more ignorant our
country does
that that's very sad it's very
unfortunate there's no no surprise here
that that parents are pulling their kids
out of school now and homeschooling it's
very difficult to do that in our modern
economy where both parents are working
and a lot of people just maybe they can
make it work but it's going to take a
little while even to Pivot what kind of
country does
that not not a great one not a not a
country that is as great as it once was
it's a country that needs to be made
great again there's a lot of podcasts
out there most of these podcasts are
people talking about their intimate
lives complaining about how America's
racist how religion is evil outside of
the daily wire it's very tough to find
podcasts that are creative and enjoyable
and intellectual and handsome you know
and of course luckily there's a great
new Catholic podcast I just heard about
podcast is called Break fast it is the
perfect mix of entertaining and
spiritual Catholic content breakfast
explains the Catholic faith through the
prism of food drink landmarks
architecture the Catholic faith is so
interwoven into our culture that we
often don't realize it even if you're
not Catholic I know many I guess most
listeners to this podcast are not
Catholic many aren't Christian many
don't even consider themselves religious
but the Catholic faith is woven into our
civilization the word breakfast for
example comes from Catholics breaking
the fast after morning Mass did you know
Sushi tempora has its roots in the
Catholic faith or how champagne was
actually created by a Catholic monk
named Dom Peron perhaps you've heard of
him the show's creators saw the need for
a podcast that is engaging accessible to
everyone of any faith or none at all
breakfast is not just a random
assortment of Catholic related facts
covers hard hitting topics and will make
you Ponder the important questions great
place to start is the episode about the
Statue of Liberty what it teaches us
about the true meaning of freedom it's a
challenging episode you won't hear it
from the mainstream media each episode
is around 20 minutes long you can
download the breakfast podcast on Apple
Spotify or anywhere you listen to
podcasts right now go to Pak shield.com
promo code nles whether you are a parent
a frequent traveler or simply seeking
professional safety you need to check
out pack Shield Pack Shield is a
ballistic insert that fits into
backpacks messenger bags and briefcases
the inserts meet the National Institute
of justice and 3A standards to stop up
to a 44 magnum Haack Shield comes in a
variety of sizes and colors plus it
weighs less than most textbooks and
laptops so it can be easily transferred
from bag to bag nice thing about them is
that no one can tell that you've got it
on your person they're extremely
lightweight they're extremely incon
conspicuous it's very impressive I know
that it is easier to keep your head down
and not think about potential threats
that you would encounter in public life
but you got to think about these things
you need to be prepared pack Shield
should never be used for any reason
other than personal defense so pack some
protection and some peace of mind with
pack Shield check them out for yourself
at Pac shield.com promo code NES kwes
for 20% off that is Pak shield.com promo
code nolles KN wle for 20% off today CBS
poll showing Haley gaining on Trump not
not nationally exactly but at least in
New Hampshire so in
Iowa Trump is faren away the leader
DeSantis comes next in New Hampshire
Trump is Far and Away the leader Haley
comes next DeSantis I think is third but
Haley is gaining pretty significantly uh
and it's not even just in the
head-to-head polls it's on all sorts of
issues so
2024 who would you likely vote for today
in New Hampshire 44% Trump 29% Haley 11%
DeSantis 10% Christie 5% V ASA
Hutchinson still in the race do you
remember that so uh it's not really
close with anyone other than Trump and
Haley 44 to 29 it's still a huge margin
but it's with within sight at
least Iowa DeSantis still far ahead of
Haley but still far behind
Trump now when you get into the cross
tabs here New Hampshire who would you
describe as prepared 54% say Trump
53% say Haley 44% say d santis Trump and
Haley virtually tied describe described
as likable who's the most likable
candidate in the race or who are you
more likely to describe as likable 55%
say Haley the majority clear majority
37% DeSantis 36 ramaswami 36 Trump so
DeSantis Ram Swami Trump All Tied chrisy
very unlikable Haley Far and Away the
most likable according to New Hampshire
voters described as reasonable 51% say
Haley 37% DeSantis 36% Trump and
DeSantis tied ha a Far and Away the
winner un most likely to be described as
reasonable described as a strong leader
66% say Trump 45% DeSantis 41% Haley
everyone else we down so DeSantis still
has an edge on Haley but close to being
tied Trump Far and Away the winner there
most likely to beat Biden
51% say
Trump 32% say Haley 27% to santis so
Haley and D santis within Striking
Distance but Haley still has the edge
Trump has a huge
lead on and on more cross
tabs that's good news for Haley that's
big news for the Haley campaign you know
how much I hate to say I told you so
but I did call it I did call it from the
beginning of this race that there were
two lanes there's the Trump TR Lane and
there's the not Trump Lane that's it and
probably it doesn't even matter who's in
the not Trump Lane because of the unique
circumstances of the almost unique
circumstances of this race we haven't
seen a race like this in over 100 years
a candidate who was president who is now
running for a non-consecutive second
term it's weird
but Trump is going in effectively as the
incumbent so the non-trump candidates
really got to be non-trump which means
it's going to be tougher for disantis
it's going to be easier for a candidate
like Nikki Haley and she's capitalizing
on that man what a great clip that was
now hey hold up ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael nlls YouTube channel
we'll see you next time